et pour en parler nous sommes avec
jacques guillaume administratrice de
l'association gay et dix élus au conseil
d'administration de l'université lyon
iii bonsoir à vous au jeune guillaume à
vos côtés jacques smith délégué national
de l'uni l'union nationale inter
universitaire merci à vous aussi d'être
avec nous alors après la tentative de
suicide d'un étudiant aux lyonnais la
semaine dernière votre association jade
guillaume tire la sonnette d'alarmé il
faut faire de la santé mentale des
étudiants une urgence nationale vous
vous êtes donc à lyon 3 quelle est la
situation sur le campus
qu'est ce que vous observez alors la
situation assez complexe guichet de
l'absence totale de vie au sein de
l'université c'est à dire que pour
l'instant on n'a encore que des courants
distant ciel donc on n'a pas de pour
l'instant il ne se passe pas grand chose
si ce n'est beaucoup d'action sur les
réseaux sociaux beaucoup d'action
virtuelle des volonté de mettre en place
des manifestations dans a essayé de
réfréner aussi par respect pour
l'étudiant en question l'idée aussi
c'est de tirer la sonnette d alarme et
de dire que voilà il faut il faut agir
et éventuellement prendre conscience de
l'urgence à laquelle les étudiants font
face alors c'est vrai que la crise
sanitaire fait évidemment beaucoup de
mal aux étudiants dont on parle parfois
d'ailleurs - parce qu'ils sont un malade
analyse justement du président de
l'université de lyon iii eric carpano
capannori côté la fermeture des
universités les cours à distance l'arrêt
des activités sportives culturelles et
festives ont favorisé l'isolément et la
détresse psychologique
un drame humain se joue que nous ne
devons pas occulter ceci nous
questionnent sur notre rôle et notre
responsabilité collective
nous devons réagir un drame humain se
joue parfois que l'on sous-estiment la
situation vous inquiète également
jacques smit
c'est une catastrophe c'est clairement
une catastrophe
cela fait maintenant dix mois que la
crise sanitaire va a débuté depuis mars
dernier on a essayé d'alerter pour le
coup toutes les organisations étudiantes
représentatives ont essayé d'alerter les
le ministère le gouvernement pour
premièrement préparer la rentrée de
septembre dernier et puis ensuite pour
préparer cette rentrée si sur le second
semestre donc de janvier 2021 pour en
reparler rien n'a été fait clairement
les étudiants sont victimes de l'inertie
du gouvernement clairement depuis dix
mois on a l'impression d'être clairement
véritablement la dernière roue du
carrosse ça joue sur trois choses
principal est d'être con pouvoir en
reparler pendant ce décryptage mais
clairement sur la qualité de la
formation on est dans l'enseignement
supérieur français pour une raison on
s'est battu pour et donc on the la
qualité de la formation derrière il y à
la crise sociale est donc là clairement
on est complètement de mort avec la
catastrophe qui a pu se dérouler ce week
end
et puis troisièmement il ya aussi le
manque d'avenir
le manque de 2,2 de weeds d'avenir pour
les étudiants qui se disent il ya déjà
est ce que je vais pouvoir passer mon
année ce que je vais pouvoir passer mon
diplôme et est ce que je vais pouvoir
trouver un job et ça clairement c'est
quelque chose qui joue sur la détresse
psychologique des étudiants ils votent
pour terminer quand on entend la
conférence de presse de jean castex que
vous êtes étudiant et que vous entendez
jean castex le 16 janvier dernier
constat dire il ya quelques jours la
semaine dernière
qui n'a pas un seul mot 1 seulement pour
la vie estudiantine et pour les
étudiants de français pour la jeunesse
française
vous vous dites que c'est quand même un
immense problème
et quand vous l'entendez ce mardi à midi
répondre que cette semaine c'est une
priorité
on peut se demander où est le bon sens
et c'est pourquoi la priorité ne pouvait
pas être ne pouvait pas être dès la
semaine dernière a exclu cette tentative
de suicide peut-être que ça fait réagir
le gouvernement rappelle à l'assemblée
aujourd'hui j'ai de guillaume mieux vaut
tard que jamais on l'espère pour vous
qu'est ce que vous attendez de la part
du gouvernement jacques smith nous dit
on se sent abandonnés mais concrètement
qu'est ce que les autorités pourraient
faire pour vous pour que ça aille mieux
alors il s'agirait d'abord de pouvoir
permettre aux universités d'étendre leur
leurs centres de santé on dit qu'il
faudrait à peu près un psychologue pour
1500 étudiants aujourd'hui on est loin
du compte et on a conscience que tout
c'est tout cet accompagnement sanitaire
nécessite des fonds et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ces fonds sont absolument
indispensables qu'on a besoin
d'accompagnement donc sanitaire santé
mais aussi numérique et je pense pas
simplement aux étudiants mais aussi aux
enseignants qui n'ont pas l'habitude de
danser naevia numérique et ce qui peut
aussi conduire à une forme de
détérioration des liens entre l'étudiant
et son enseignant également de
détérioration de la formation elle-même
puisque finalement un enseignant qui n'a
jamais donné de cours ni par web ex ni
par zoom se retrouve dans une grande
incapacité
alors si le fait le choix de s'adapter
et qu'il a une formation à ce moment là
ça peut se passer ça peut bien se passer
mais sinon on est dans une grande dans
un as dans une forme d'attentisme entre
ses professeurs qui n'arrivent plus à
enseigner et ses étudiants qui ne
parviennent plus à apprendre et je crois
qu'il faut un accompagnement de des
autorités sur cette nouvelle formation
qui est maintenant virtuel se distend
ciel et qu'il faut pas attendre que les
drames comme celui ci se produisent
avant de réagir alors justement me lance
des étudiants ont publié une tribune
celle des derniers des confiné c'est une
lettre ouverte à emmanuel macron dans
laquelle il dénonce ce dont vous parlez
à l'accès des étudiants aux cours en
présentiel regarder en limitant l'accès
des étudiants en cours en présentiel
c'est toute une génération que vous
sacrifiez et l'avenir du pays que vous
mettez en danger
jacques smith sont vraiment ces courants
distant ciel qui cristallise le mal être
des étudiants
vous savez quand vous passez tout votre
semaine de lundi matin 8 heures au
samedi soir 20h en visio derrière un
écran d'ordinateur
je crois pas qu'on puisse parler d'une
vie étudiante correct et est pour le
moins épanouissante
un étudiant un jeune n'est pas fait pour
rester cloîtré dans un oeuf est carré un
jeune de 20 ans n'est pas fait pour cela
vous quand vous regardez des chiffres
alors c'est toujours intéressant avec
les limites que l'on connaît aux
chiffres et aux enquêtes
mais quand vous voyez que près de 23% et
est donc un cinquième des étudiants ont
conlu des pensées suicidaires
je crois ne pas m'avancer trop fort et
trop loin en disant qu'il ne fallait pas
clairement attendre ce week-end et la
catastrophe et ceux venus pour
effectivement comprendre que ledit
essentielle est que la langue de vie
sociale et que le manque de proximité de
camaraderie et de la vie étudiante tout
simplement peuvent amener à une détresse
psychologique
il lance donc aujourd'hui ce qu'on
demande au ministère c'est déjà de tout
simplement d'aider les établissements
est de réunir des universités alors bien
évidemment avec les conditions
sanitaires et dans le respect de deux de
ses de ses gestes barrières de la
distanciation sociale mais en tout cas
quand on dit qu'avant noël et il y avait
eu toute une communication du
gouvernement
en dix ans nous avons discuté avec tous
les présidents des universités avec la
cpu pour pouvoir dès le lundi 4 janvier
commençait à réouvrir en présentiel ou
nous a parlé de groupes de 10 personnes
on nous a parlé le groupe de t&d en 2011
eh bien ça fait une semaine et demie du
coup maintenance et on se rend bien
compte que c'est un échec que c'est un
échec et que quand madame vidal nous
parle d'un possible d'une possible
réouverture des bars retour à la normale
début février
on se dit qu'on est bien loin de cet
objectif et donc on leur demande tout
simplement de 2 d'avancé sur sur ce
projet là on précise qu'un rapport
parlementaire mi décembre avait déjà mis
en lumière qu'un jeune sur six eux
auraient arrêté ses études depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire ça fait
beaucoup quand on vous écoute on
s'inquiète un peu parce que c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui tous
d'un éventuel troisième confinement est
ce que ça va être vivable survival si
j'ose dire même si c'est pas français
pour vous vous le craignez on imagine
énormément ce confinement français si je
peux me permettre je voudrais donner
simplement l'exemple des étudiants
lycéens qui ont passé de l'année
dernière donc le coc vide dans leur
année avec locaux vides ils n'ont pas
passé le bac ils ont passé la plupart de
leurs aînés en distance yale et leur
première année donc de licence 1 pour
ceux qui sont à l'université a été
également en distance yale donc depuis
deux ans ils n'ont vécu aucun examen
si ce n'est des examens en présentiel
pour certaines facultés et encore et ils
n'ont jamais eu la chance de s'intégrer
alors repoussé faire encore un
confinement où on élargir est ce cet
extracteur laquelle fracture numérique
est une fracture sociale mais aussi une
fracture psychologique et une inquiétude
aussi pour se dire ok donc là je ne sais
pas où je suis je sais pas trop ce que
ce que je dois faire mais je sais pas
non plus où je vais et je crois que
l'étudiant ce qu'il a besoin c'est d'un
but il a besoin de se dire là je je vais
passer mon diplôme je vais la voir je
vais pouvoir passer l'année suivante
retrouver mes amis m'inscrire dans des
associations et tout ça ça n'existe plus
mais reconnaît il s'accroche merci à
vous en tout cas à tous les deux bon
courage en tout cas j'adore guillaume
jacques smith en espérant pour vous
d'avoir des bonnes nouvelles évidemment
merci d'avoir été en direct sur rt
francs